how's it going guys my name is Matt
you're watching KOAT eken toriel's my
youtube channel today we're going to be
talking about bullet physics bullet
physics is a C++
physics library guess that's what we
call it and you can find it on github
there's a lot to it that I don't know
yet so I'll just start that with this
with start this with that disclaimer I'm
going to show you how to basically get
it up and running on Windows it looks
like you can do it on any OS you want
windows it seems to be fairly easy well
this is used in a ton of games and it
was just a very it's one of the more
common ways to get physics into your
game I don't want to say that like there
aren't other options but of course judge
for yourself okay let's go ahead and get
this going so there's a lot of stuff
there basically what you need to know if
you're on Windows is you're going to
need a Visual Studio Community Edition
so let's go ahead and find a Visual
Studio Community Edition and I assume
you already have this if you're
developer and using Windows because why
wouldn't you and here it is so basically
when you install this and set it up just
click the C++ workflow and install that
along with it and you're pretty much
good to go
on that and we'll come back to that so
what we're gonna do here is just go to
clone or download or you know we could
also go to releases and we could get the
latest release source code and build
that but we're just going to go ahead
and I guess we'll clone the master so it
should be pretty close to the latest
release with maybe a few more fixes
okay so cloning the master we can also
get it as a zip or we can clone it with
github stuff I'm just going to download
a zip for now so I don't have to sign in
and as you can see at the bottom of my
screen there it is downloading give it
time
give it time there goes it looks like
it's finished I'm just gonna click it to
open it right away but you may have to
go to your directory where you saved it
and open it or whatever I'm just using
my browser feature so there it is it's
in downloads it's in a zip so I want to
get it out of here and put it in its own
directory so I'm just gonna right-click
and do a copy just live any copy no but
it does let me extract so we'll go ahead
and do that I'm using P zip you might
have a different unpacking program but
I'm just gonna click extract here and
I'm just gonna put it in source on my
drive here and that should do it looks
like it's all unpacked so we're gonna go
ahead and close this and just open up my
thingamajigger my drives code my
username go to source and there it is of
course you want to go to wherever you
unpack it that's up to you and however
you want to do your hard drive everybody
has different ways seems like so okay so
what you want to do here is you want to
look for this one here build visual
studio VR PI Boulud devil I haven't
tested the others maybe there's stuff
that's relevant on those two but I've
just only used this one so that's what
I'm going to show you so I'm just gonna
run this or hit open and what this does
you might get an unsafe warning in might
have to allow it but basically what it
does is it gets the build ready for
Visual Studio and opens the folder at
the end for you and you just want to
click this top one the zero bullet three
solution and this will open the bullet
project now since you're probably well
since these were configured 420 Visual
Studio 2010 you got to do this
target you basically just hit okay here
and let it do its thing and it's fine
okay very good so now we have a visual
studio project our solution open and
over here there's the main solution and
then there's a whole bunch of sub
projects and it looks like it starts you
off on the one called applet example
browser and you can go look at the code
and that and the extras and whatever
else they have and you can do that for
any of these projects you can just go
look at the code and see how they're how
they're done you can also right-click on
any of these and go to properties and
see the properties that are set on this
particular project or sub project so a
lot of things worth studying on this and
and figuring out but basically you'll
see these apps here all kind of run
something in a window for the most part
and the main projects here that
everything else works off of it seems to
be all these bullet file or collision
comm and dynamics geometry so pretty
much all these are used to these create
libraries these for the most part no I
don't know about every single one I
haven't looked at every single one super
carefully because it just takes forever
I've been going through it so yeah those
are built as libraries of this other
stuff uses it and stuff like that so if
you right-click on any of these and go
to I don't know for example build
dependencies and then project build or
order or project dependencies let's
click on project dependencies you'll see
that this applet example browser depends
on some of these libraries other
projects so these other projects will
build when you build it this is all
visual studio stuff maybe this should be
an entire different video but this is
stuff you know I had to figure out so I
just figured maybe other people do too
and as you can see if I click on these
bullet ones they don't really rely on
anything else because they're their own
library these apps rely on
the library's so that's just something
to keep in mind something you can do in
your own projects to make libraries sub
projects for your other stuff pretty
cool okay so if I just hit play here
it's gonna build and run ample example
browser 32 and all of its dependencies
and debug its 32-bit I'm gonna go ahead
and hit play on that and let it do its
thing so if you're doing it too this is
all you should have to do you should
literally just be able to hit play and
get this example browser and I'll show
you a few more things after this
finishes and then we'll call it a video
array and there we are okay there's the
first basic example and you can hold alt
and drag around all the stuff I'm going
to tell you is probably in the
instructions too or if you're just
reading a lot you'll figure it out too
because that's how I figured most of
this out and you can zoom with the mouse
you can click and drag and test things
and other little projects here there's a
rolling friction one so they fell on a
slant it looks like oh and things just
kind of rolling constraints so you can
go through all these projects there we
go and it takes a moment to load them
okay but I will warn you because I was
clicking through these kind of in PEM
fun at one point I got to something that
crashed and I couldn't recover from it
and I think it was in this deformable
body so just a fair warning you might
want to skip some of those at first
until you're prepared dent I have a
crash I think I'm pretty sure was it was
like the grasp on some deformable cloth
or something so it was like one of these
and I was troubleshooting a little bit
then it was just taking too long and I
was like I don't I don't feel like
troubleshooting this so I didn't exactly
figure out what's wrong but it seemed
like an asset problem so yeah you can
click on any of these and get a little
demo
a little scared to click on ones I
haven't clicked on yet because I don't
know if they're gonna do the crash thing
I was talking about but let's just go
through this first set I think this
first set is pretty safe so horizontal
hinge I think you just and what do you
do you move this okay drag it left and
right so it's uh yeah motorized okay
there's another hinge torque it says
test hinge torque I don't know what's
going on here 60 of spring - lets click
that can we make this larger yeah okay
this is way better
sorry so is this some kind of engine
type thing I guess I don't know motor
demo eat gyroscopic already soft contact
so you get the point you can go play
with these and check out the code and
see how it's all done now as far as
including what you need into your own
project then it'll have to be a second
topic in probably the second video if
you have any trouble shoot comment down
below and yeah we'll figure it out so if
you want to try any of these other ones
you just the last thing you can right
click and you set a start up project it
looks like this example browser is kind
of a cool one to start as oops not
retarget okay she's just so much stuff
well hope you enjoyed and I'll see you
in the next video peace out
you